[موسيقى]
تسبب حزب الله اللبناني في ايصال مد
العقوبات ضده الى مسؤولين بارزين في
باراجواي على دفتر العقوبات الامريكيه تم
ادراج الرئيس السابق هوراسيو كارتس ونائب
الرئيس الحالي
لصلتهما باعضاء في حزب الله وزاره الخزانه
الامريكيه فرضت عقوبات على المسؤولين بسبب
تفشي الفساد بما يقوض المؤسسات
الديمقراطيه كما ادرج مكتب مراقبه الاصول
الاجنبيه بوزاره الخزانه اربعه كيانات
يسيطر عليها رئيس باراغواي السابق في
قائمته السوداء وزاره الخزانه اوضحه ان كل
من نائب الرئيس الحالي والرئيس السابق في
باراغواي تربتهما صلاتهم باعضاء في جماعه
حزب الله اللبنانيه وذكرت ان حزب الله نظم
فعاليات على نحو منتظم لتبادل الهدايا
والريشه في باراغواي التي تضم جهاليه
اللبنانيه كبيره
كما اوضحت الوزاره ان العقوبات تعني حضر
جميع ممتلكات ومصالح كارتس وبلاسكيز في
الولايات المتحده
علاقه جديده تتكشف فصولها تباعا بين
مسؤولين بارزين في باراغواي وحزب الله
اللبنانيه المدرج من الولايات المتحده
ودول غربيه اخرى على قائمه المنظمات
الارهابيه